I find it so sad today this idea but I
have different needs you are good for
this you are good for that no sorry this
is not love love is something else it's
much more non-conditional when I was
young there was a more conservative
erotic pedagogy to have multiple
partners was considered pathological
even psychoanalysts were usually anal
what are you why are you running from
one woman to another what are you
escaping from your mother or what now in
Argentina maybe the most psychoanalyzed
country in the world if you run from one
woman to the other
for women also if you trained Partners
it's considered normal if you are
faithful to your partner they say oh my
God this is pathological fixation we
have to analyze it and so on